by
[Music]
it's an incredibly exciting time to have
you here there's so much going on in the
auto industry and before we delve into
the trends within that and potentially
all your personal career and the
leadership that you've shown it be great
to look at the space as a whole and it
seems at the moment there's a sort of
existential threat where the need and
indeed the desire to own cars is is
coming down how do you lead such a huge
iconic company in that context well I
think you know we obviously we do a lot
of research to understand what's
happening we're definitely seeing people
are deciding to buy vehicles later
depending on where they live in if you
put the customer in the center of how
you look at this it doesn't surprise me
that if you're in New York City and you
pay a lot of money for a car you pay a
lot of money to park it when you get it
out to drive it you're in stop-and-go
traffic when you get to where you want
to go you're going to pay a lot of money
to park it if you can find a place and
so you start to look at all of those as
customer pain points and you start to
say people are still going to need to
move from point A to point B but
depending on if they're in a denser of
an environment you know what are they
going to need to travel with them you
know are they a single individual are
they you know do they have three
children and a pack and play I mean so I
think we try to look at it to say let's
really understand the customer and let's
understand how we can create value for
them and how we can provide new
experiences that are better for them and
you know that kind of drives us on how
we make decisions about what we invest
in and you know different concepts of
you know why we did the alliance with
lyft why we bought cruise automation why
we started around car-sharing program
maven it's all with this intent to make
sure that we're looking and saying how
do we provide the most value for the
customer as they get from point A to
point B all right and in these times of
sort of quick change presumably that
requires a change of behavior equally at
a General Motors and you know it over a
hundred years old over two hundred
thousand employees and I'm sure you know
these stats and
but more seriously historically the
focus has been on long product cycle on
lean operations not on taking risks on
iterating quickly as we move from a
hardware centric world to a more
software focused one how do you had you
change the behaviors become more dynamic
more entrepreneurial well you make a
really good point and we've invested a
lot of time that one of the you know
people have this hundred-year-old view
of General Motors and you know one of
the stats that I throw up it usually
surprises people is almost 40% of the
employees the salaried workforce has
been with the company less than five
years and so we are you know there's a
lot of new talent that has come to the
company as we've done that we've you
know kind of mix remix the shift of
there used to be a lot of people who
worked on body structures and that we
have a lot more software engineers in
the technical area so you know we really
managed how we shift the skillset of the
organization because even if you take
the traditional car ten years ago when
you look at a car you know it had a
radio maybe had some systems on it but
now every vehicle we make even you know
I'll say the most based vehicle has tens
of millions of lines of code in it so
we've been making that shift and have a
lot of new talent that has come to the
company but then the second part of your
question is you know we're a long
development cycle if you start from you
know from a blank of computer screen not
a piece of paper you're really going to
be on a four to five year development
plan to put a new power into the
marketplace but when we're doing a maven
a new offering for maven it's on a weak
cycle you know it's how quickly do you
softly do create the software to add the
new functionality to the app and so
we've really had to challenge ourselves
to no one we need to move at a vehicle
development cycle because in our
business you know the average age of a
car is eleven point four I think it's
over eleven point four years so we're
making a product that's going to be on
the road for a very long time and has to
be you know safety is an overriding
priority with that but yet in different
aspects of our business now it's really
you know what is the Minimum Viable
Product to put forward that will really
start to add value so we have to be
working we talked about working at both
speeds one of the great things was
acquiring cruise automation
because what we've done with crews and
we've now given them responsibility not
only to develop the the artificial
intelligence or the specific software
for autonomous you know linked into the
major technical resources of the company
but we've also given them the
responsibility for commercialization and
we have I'll say a very thin line of a
handful of people that they go to when
they want to you know leverage the vast
resources of General Motors there's like
a pretty hard wall with the the big
company wanting to go into the startup
because we don't want to overwhelm them
with help and slow them down and so it's
really allowed us to kind of learn at
I'll say it startup speed how to run a
major you know major initiative a very
important you know program that we're
working on from an autonomous driving
perspective and we're able to start to
infuse that type of thinking into the
broader organization so you know the
added benefit of acquiring crews was not
only the wonderful technology and the
talented people but it was also just
driving the whole company to work at a
start-up speed and speaking about
autonomous cars I think we all
acknowledge now it's a matter of when
not s what should we're sort of citizens
be most excited about in that
transformation what what should we be
most concerned about I think we should
be most excited about is safety because
96% if you look at the latest statistics
96% of all fatalities and this is us
data because it's readily available our
due to human error and so as you get
into autonomous vehicles you are going
to be moving to a much safer way to to
be moving from point A to point B so I
think that's one of the most significant
that also is you know if done well is
more convenient gives you time back you
can be doing other things in the vehicle
having different experiences or in the
call in a vehicle but inmate whatever we
want to call what moves you from point A
to point B you know I think worried
about is I don't know if the customer is
necessarily worried but I think it's
also I wouldn't call it a worry as much
as an understanding is that for a very
long time autonomous vehicles are going
to be interacting with you know vehicles
driven by humans and
you know it's going to be moving to a
much safer place but that doesn't mean
that you know everything is going to be
perfect nothing in life is perfect no
software program is is infinitely
perfect and so I think understanding you
know how we make that transition in
today's world I think will be important
that we spend some time educating but
also helping people understand what the
technology is capable of what it's not
and especially where we're going to be
for a very long time we'll be in a world
that has both and then you mentioned the
significant investment you made in and
lift earlier I think at one point there
was even talk of potentially acquiring
it but what's the game plan there and
particularly given what's happened more
recently how do you think of trying to
delete uber
well that's best that you know that's
that's what's objective I would imagine
it would the way we look at it and why
we did the Alliance is we believe that
autonomous driving for an consumer will
first happen in a shared environment now
why is that a one is because as the
vehicles you first put the vehicle out a
will want to own it until you know go
through the reference cycles of you know
getting the sensor crossed down there's
gonna there's going to be cost so it's
going to make sense to have it in a
shared environment but also because the
vehicle will start with limited
capability right now we're limited on
how fast the vehicle can go based on how
fast we can process the data coming in
from the sensors you know that will
change and that will change rapidly so
what will happen the cost curve will go
down is the capability curve goes up of
you know how does it manage a tunnel how
does it manage you know different snow
and fog and all the other you know
different elements and so I think that
as we look at it that's that's why it
was so important to have you know an
alliance and we've actually learned a
lot about the shared the ride sharing
space through our alliance but very
important because that's where we think
the first major opportunity is for
autonomous vehicles
so maybe summing up all these kind of
them subsea questions
what does General Motors look like in
ten years time twenty years time you
know I don't think anyone knows but I
think you know my view and what I work
every day to make sure is that General
Motors is a leading the transformation
because then when I look at the assets
that we have not only the deep technical
talent that of doing you know get
machines that in technology platforms
that are on the roads for more than a
decade and leading and how do we focus
on the customer to make sure that you
know it's not just technology because we
can but how do we solve real issues how
do we make the the world better from a
you know customer perspective from an
environmental perspective from a
congestion perspective and so I believe
with all the assets we have that we have
a unique ability and responsibility to
lead that transformation to do it
exceptionally well and improve the whole
transportation space the political
environment is also seeing significant
changes a big part of than president
Trump's campaign was bringing jobs back
to the US
General Motors has manufacturing hubs
all over the world you're also part of
his Business Council how do you sort of
balance sad and how do you think about
bringing all manufacturing jobs back to
the US well I think first our general
philosophy is where we built we build
where we sell and in the United States
for example 74 some of the vehicles we
sell in the United States are built in
the United States if we look at just
total number vehicles built here versus
sold here it approaches 80 percent so we
do have a lot of jobs you know we have
over a hundred thousand jobs in this
country alone so part of it was making
sure people understood understood our
industry we also though you know my
responsibility is to manage the company
and deploy capital in the best interest
of our owners our shareholders and so
I've got to look at that and make sure
it easiest thing in the world say oh I'm
going to build a factor here and I'm
going to bring a bunch of jobs here but
if that's not sustainable if that wasn't
the best decision for the company it's a
very temporary situation because you
jobs you know you have to have a vibrant
strong company to have job security and
provide jobs over the long haul I think
that's what the the end goal is here
you know we work on you know what how do
we make manufacturing more competitive
here how do we you know take away their
across the globe there isn't necessarily
a level playing field and and you know
what can come in versus that can be
exported so there's a lot that we can
work on that it's going to improve drops
but the foundation of it has to be good
business economic sense otherwise it's
not sustainable and you really haven't
done it in the long term it's not going
to do anyone anyway it's not good for
anyone
so looking specifically I have one of
the president Trump's tweets it said
general motors are sending mexican-made
model of Chevy Cruze to US car dealers
tax-free across border making us or pay
big board attacks they they never they
never sounded good when you read them
out General Motors is clearly not alone
in facing tweets from President Trump
given particularly that the lack of
clearly defined policy that we've seen
how do you how do you react to tweet
like that I think the first thing is
don't overtrain on it because if you
step back and say okay his message is
jobs that's pretty clear you know we
were within you know I don't think it
was an hour before that tweet came out
we were able to put the facts on that's
specific vehicle but yes is build in
Mexico but you know then it becomes the
economics of building cars we probably
fell I don't know of less than 10,000 of
those vehicles in the United States
because a hatch is something that you
know there it's a segment that people
want but not you know it's not a
dominant segment and that's true for
most countries so placing that business
in Mexico with all the free trade
agreements they have allows you to offer
that vehicle if you said I can only
offer it if I build it here I wouldn't
capitalize it so it wouldn't be
available and so part of it was just
explaining that explaining that the
cruise
the Cruze Sedan is built in Lordstown
Michigan and you know a factory is
dedicated to it I think that pretty much
subdued that but but I stepped back and
said I'm not going to over train on the
tweet I'm certainly not going to get
into a tweeting exchange
let's put the fact I didn't have those
sweets yeah because but but if you think
about it I step back and said okay what
what is the real message and let's now
work constructively on what of trying to
create more jobs you know one of the
things I'm really proud about at General
Motors is with a hundred thousand people
we employ those are good middle-class or
better jobs in this country I'm really
proud of the jobs that we provide so
let's look at how does it make good
business sense for us to do more of that
as opposed to responding to a tweet okay
and I guess the more formally lots of
potential trade policy coming up is
there anything that you're thinking will
benefit John motive substantially or
workers in the rusco I mean I think
workers across the country but I think
getting a level playing field I mean I
think that's all we can really ask we
shouldn't ask for advantage you know
that is artificial get my opinion let's
let's have an equal playing field and
then you know I can create more jobs if
I sell more vehicles if I'd you know
make more vehicles here that I can
export because it's not a 10 20 or 30
percent tax as they is they're sent to
another country may our main message is
a level playing field and then let us
compete and and we're you know will bet
on us and then we we saw that some CEO
said Travis from from Guba obviously
chose not to be part of that Business
Council in the end after a reaction from
from their user base with that something
that crossed your mind as well given
with parts of your customers that it's
an unpopular administration you know
first of all it's our it's our
administration you know we may I have
voted in many elections and there's been
times you know the candidate I voted for
was elected and there's been times that
candidate hasn't been but it then is our
government and so when you're asked to
serve and you know with is important as
our industry is to the country and and
and jobs and and what we do cannot take
the seat at the table if it's offered to
you I just think is is a missed
opportunity and so when I represent the
company and
to have that voice into the government I
think is vitally important and I think
it's proven to be very important for us
to communicate a very complex supply
chain as it related to the border tax
initially when those conversations or
the fact that there wasn't a level
playing field across many countries that
can send vehicles here with no with no
tax or to talk about job creation and
job training and you know there's just
been a whole host of issues that we've
been able to have a strong voice into it
so to miss that opportunity I wouldn't
consider that and you mentioned having a
seat at the table would you ever
consider a more permanent seat at the
table okay I think I just answered that
question about a week and half ago but
now I've been at General Motors for 37
years there is just so many exciting
things we're working on with
transforming the industry that that's
where my heart is that's where my
passion is and that's where all where I
will work and I think I can contribute
to if we if we execute what we're what
we're working on I think that we can
really contribute to the country and to
the globe because we do business in many
countries so I think I think that's
where I belong okay I will I'll change
my tracking so one of the other things
is obviously what widely consider is one
of the faces of successful women in
business there sometimes appears to be
an expectation that that will never make
you a champion of women in the workplace
is that is that ever something that's
frustrating or how do you how do you
handle that well I guess I'd like to be
a champion of people in the workplace
because I believe fundamentally that you
when you you know you'll have a create
the best experience have the best
results when you engage the hearts and
minds of your of your people so I mean
that's the way I look at it is there you
know clearly if I can be a role model
for young women to want to pursue a
career in stem which i think is so
vitally important or for them to say I'm
going to aspire to do this because I've
seen her and she did it so why can't I
and if I can provide that role model I
you know that that makes me extremely
happy I had
in my first year in the job I had
somebody come up to me and said because
of you my daughter has chosen to study
engineering and it was like one of the
best comments who could get and so you
know for sure that that is very
meaningful at General Motors because you
know you can't say diversity is so
vitally important for the success of our
company and it's not something that you
can say well I did it and it's done it's
something you continually work on a
champion a group of the most senior
women to the top 35 women in the company
but it's really for me it's getting them
to say okay you know don't come to me
and tell me everything that's wrong
you're a senior person in this company
so tell me how you're going to solve
those problems and what you're going to
do to make it better and you know we now
meet three to four times a year and work
on what are some of the issues with
women in diversity because what I found
earlier in my career is I worked on
diversity is generally a lot of times
when you solve issues for women you
solve issues for everyone because a lot
of times men have the same issues or you
know if it's a minority issue or
whatever it is a lot of it can get
solved with with solving the women the
issue that's termed the woman's issue
and so I'm dedicated to that but but I
also believe you know it's if you want
to win the hearts and minds of your
entire team and if we now look back to
sort of the start of your career and you
came to as a co-op student with with
general most of them spent 37 years
rising to the top a lot of us now I
think would don't expect to have such a
long term career at one company what
would be your advice for us in
considering that and if you're reviewing
CV or sorry resumes now how do you think
about someone that's maybe got a wider
breadth of knowledge versus a depth of
knowledge and someone that stayed in one
place a long time well you know I you
need people who have breadth and depth
depending on what the role is so I look
for that I don't necessarily look and
say oh this person's been at four
companies and this person's been at one
I want to sometimes understand because
if the person's been at four companies
why did they leave and a lot of times
they leave for very good reasons
sometimes they'll you know if you get to
a point where well I had an issue here
then I had the same issue here and I had
the same issue here and I have the same
issue here maybe you're the issue and so
you know I kind of want to probe a
little on that but beyond that it
that's not important to me it's really
what the skills and abilities and
experiences that they bring in the
leadership that they bring you know I've
been at General Motors for 37 years I
wouldn't say when I started and
graduated as a co-op student that I was
going to be here I didn't have this plan
Allah will be at General Motors for 37
years I kept having great experiences
put in front of me they sent me here you
know we were just talking in the back
bed when I first came back from the
business school there had been a lot of
change in turmoil and I didn't have the
best job and I you know wasn't one of
those that I was passionate about and
you know fortunately in about a year's
period of time and especially by - the
situation changed and I chose to stay so
I also leave in your career life's too
short to work for a company or be in a
position that you don't love now you
know work is work I had this funny text
from my nephew who's now graduating from
a BBA in business school at Michigan and
it was his first job and he texted me
you know I'm sitting at a computer I've
got to do all this work in spreadsheets
and I and you know submit you know kind
of was like this isn't much fun I said
yeah that's why they call it work and
it's just you know you're going to have
to work and that every day is you know
you can't measure your career on every
day but if you find yourself after six
months after a year that you know work
is not challenging or you don't enjoy it
or you're not energized by it you should
probably find something else to do again
because life's too short I am fortunate
after 37 years in and again it wasn't
always just a straight line there were
ups and downs in that curve but I've
been offered tremendous opportunities
which you can have at a big company like
a company like General Motors you know
to be haven't worked in Communications
and HR and run an assembly plant and you
know machinery you know led the
machinery and equipment purchased for
the globe and product development I mean
I just I feel like I've had a bunch of
careers they just all happened to have
been at General Motors and so having had
two years and at the GSB
and to enjoyed the life in California
the transition back to Detroit with that
was that an easy one and I guess
graduates again here
Detroit is probably not one of the
places that a lot of us are looking for
work how do you how do you how do you
think about that now or what are the
positives were missing about Detroit
well there's so many well first of all
it's easy for me to go back home because
that's where my husband was so and
that's where my family was and I'm a
pretty family-oriented person so you
know if I had been if General Motors had
said hey you could stay here I probably
would said well unless my husband's
coming here I want to go there but again
family weren't a person at the time you
know my parents were there and so that
wasn't that hard to decision now you
know I have to admit every one of the
reasons I love being on the stand for a
guisard board for the GSB as well as the
Board of Trustees I love the Bay Area
and you know one of the things that I in
glenwood remember this when we design we
actually do a program a custom program
for our top leadership and we're in our
third I think completing our third
cohort now it's a program that runs
through a year with four different weeks
and when I first came to the school I
said I you know Silicon Valley doesn't
have the or you know Palo Alto you don't
have the lock on innovation and
creativity and I want to infuse that
back into the company actually across
the globe and that was the kind of the
start of designing the program that we
did around design thinking and
leadership and it's actually one of the
most popular classes that training the
art class is a Development Program it's
probably of all time so it's it's
something that has worked out
exceptionally well so you know it's a
beautiful climate there's a lot of
energy here but what Detroit is
different Detroit you have seasons you
have
oh come on
but you know and my mother used to say
that too but III do say just to be
totally honest it's been ever since I
spent two years out here I think my
Bloods been because I'm always cold when
it's winter if it's below 60 it's just
cold however said that I do enjoy you
know it is a different climate it's in
you know the Midwest is a different type
of community and that's where I've grown
up so that's home for me and so I do
enjoy it and again what I think is so
interesting about Detroit right now and
again if you don't like the cold you're
not going to be happy I'm not going to
try to put a you know a bow on that but
what is really exciting right now to be
in Detroit is because the city is is
going through just a complete
Renaissance and it's fun to be a part of
that it's fun to see the new restaurants
start up and the new you know the new
cultural things that you can do and and
just to be a part of how we're
reinvigorating the city the answer
ownership people coming to the town to
watch the new buildings come up you know
I joked about the fact that they built a
Whole Foods in downtown Detroit which
five years ago people would have been
like no but to build a Whole Foods in
that's the biggest problem with the
Whole Foods is the parking lots not big
enough because it's you know when you
look at all the you know the young and
professionals that have come into the
city when they work all day you know
it's part of their routine so it's
really fun to be a part of the city that
is is going through this rebirth and to
be a part of it and you know the other
thing why we're drawing a lot of
entrepreneurs there is because it's
pretty cheap to live there so you can
start a new business you can launch
something so I love it here but I love
it there that makes sense and if we now
go jump a little bit ahead in your
career and you became CEO there were
other internal candidates in the running
they changed from peers to becoming
people that reported them to you how did
you handle that transition well I think
first of all we had we had a strong
relationship before we had worked
together before and I have a very
collaborative leadership style so I want
to get the best views on the table
and I think because we knew each other
so well it wasn't like I said something
that everybody froze and I want people
to challenge me I'm going to you know
come at an issue what if I've got a
point of view I'm going to come at it
pretty hard and be pretty convicted but
if someone presents a compelling
counterpoint I want to hear that and so
I try to make sure there's a lot of
constructive tension and that all views
are heard I mean there's times on really
important decisions where I go to every
single person around the table and say
what do you think and and and I've also
done work with my senior leadership team
to build trust we actually do offsites
two to three times a year where we go in
to make sure you know we know how to
give each other constructive negative
feedback and and and have a direct
conversation where I don't agree with
him it's not personal but so I think
because that's my style of being pretty
collaborative we were able to work
through it pretty quickly you know there
was probably a couple little you know
where you kind of had to renegotiate
what the you know how the relationship
was going to work but I would say you
know a few weeks maybe a few months in
it was kind of a non-issue and that time
collaborative style is that partly
because of the experience you had at the
GSB as well the offsites you talked
about and it sounds like some of the
courses that we do here is with that
like a big part of that the
collaborative style that you used you
know it's a good question I mean I
learned so much here I always say when
people ask me you know what did you
learn I mean I didn't know what I didn't
know I mean I you know I had an
engineering background I had worked in a
big company but you know more in a
focused area and so it was so broadening
to come here and understand the several
aspects of business so it's always been
a foundation for me but you know I think
your point it probably does route back
to all those group projects you're doing
now where you know you could probably
write the paper a little faster but it
wouldn't be as good because it wouldn't
in you know be fusing together for views
or having those debates about what's
better and I think you're right I think
it it there's Valley it takes more time
but in the end you get I think a much
better answer that you can then execute
because the other thing is you once you
you go through that process of debating
everybody's on board if you you know if
your
well you get everyone on board and then
you execute a lot faster Sampson
then right at the time that you did
become CEO you had to immediately handle
the faulty ignition switch crisis and
how if you had been CEO before that role
and in the direct aftermath was there
anything that you could have done
differently or any changes that you
could have made to it to avoid it you
know clearly if we'd known about it
sooner we could have made better
decisions but you know one of the things
that I think is not well known from the
way that it was covered in the media was
this this was an issue that was
unfortunate that over a long period of
time mistakes were made but it was the
internal company you know and actually
the team who finally figured out what
was happening and brought the issue
forward and we decided to do the recall
so but clearly there were a lot of
mistakes made along the way and you know
I don't know the minute we found out
about it we acted and the minute we knew
you know we we were guided by three
principles of doing the right thing for
the customer being transparent and doing
everything in our power to make sure it
never happened again which meant
changing a lot of processes and the way
work was done and so I think it's one of
those things you don't get to choose
when you have a crisis when you have it
you know you have to deal with it then
and and you don't get to put it off and
say why I'll deal with that next month
you deal with it now because that's just
the way the world works and so at that
time you made a significant effort to
rebuild General Motors images image with
increased number of public appearances
and so on
how did you consider trying to be
proactive versus reactive in that time
of crisis I think you have to be
proactive because it's you know
especially with how fast communications
happen today if you don't tell you know
if you don't get the facts out on the
table that void will be filled with
misinformation and so we thought it was
very important that's why you know
transparency was one of the kind of the
guiding principles we use to make sure
we were being updated at the same time
you can't answer questions you don't
know the answer to and so there were
times where I had to say I don't
no and you know I was criticized for
that when I went to Congress and you
know even made fun of on Saturday Night
Live but that was the fun thing to wake
up to and my brother calling me Mary
Mary I'm like oh my gosh but you know
you don't really you you have to you
have to tell the story and you have to
answer the questions when you know the
answer one of the things and I encourage
all of you because you're so tempted
because you think you know what happened
until you know what happened
you can't answer had I done that I would
have answered wrong and I would have
probably caused a lot more harm to the
company so you know you want to you want
to get to the facts as quickly as you
can but if you don't have facts you
can't you know it's just this race ring
because you got to move as fast as you
can but you have to do with facts and
and for me that the way I worked on that
was to have a cross-functional team that
had you know kind of had oh here's the
engineering view and the finance view
and the legal view and the
communications view and the state you
know the customer sales view let's all
get in a room and let's figure out what
are we all hearing what do we need to do
what are the facts are you sure okay now
we're going to move and now as you look
back over your career one of the quotes
I saw as we were preparing to this is
that you've never asked for a raise and
if you were now at the start of that
career journey would you think about
that differently you know edit I guess
the way I look at it it is kind of gets
back to what I said before if you don't
love your job if you don't think whether
it's you don't think you're being fairly
compensated or challenged or it's not a
fulfilling job you need to act on that I
think I found through my career pay
wasn't one of the issues that I had it
had I you know I wasn't saying never do
it I'm just saying I found myself in a
position where there were times I had
asked for saying hey I know this is my
job now and I'm you know I'm going to do
this really well but here might here or
where my interests are and I'd like to
you know be have the opportunity to be
considered for roles in this area I
think that's your obligation and I you
know I did proactively advocate for
myself in those types of situations I
just never had an issue where I thought
I wasn't being fairly compensated
and final question for me now before we
open up to the audience and also spose
the research we read about you're sort
of never happier than actually on the
test track putting the cars through
their paces is there anything else we
would be potentially surprised to know
that probably but you know I just from a
work perspective you know again I people
say why did you stay at General Motors
so long you know there is something
about the auto industry and there's been
a couple of times now where we've had
people leave the industry and come back
and when they interview and I'll say so
why do you want to come back and well
because I miss it because there is
something there's just an excitement
about you know building cars or trucks
or crossovers and you know people name
them and they write songs about them and
they pick it because you know this fits
my personality or this fits my
functionality but you know for a lot of
people occurrence kind of an extension
of themselves and it's fun to be in that
business and then you know doing me
where I feel like we're you know we're
in the technology business we're in the
fashion business and so I just I love I
love the industry and I would say my
best days or they're spending time at
design staff because then you're looking
at what is the next generation of this
or what is the all-new vehicle in this
segment going to be and I you know the
minute I see it I'm like oh you know why
is that two years out I want it now or
you know getting to spend time in our
Milford proving grounds or some of the
test trucks we have around the world and
driving our vehicles and you know what I
was running product development every
Friday afternoon we'd go out to the to
our proving grounds and we drive our new
cars or cars that were under development
we drove it against the competition and
we'd spend the afternoon and it was it's
what we do so it's it's it's a lot of
fun
well this fine I'll then look to my
colleagues
hi my name is Maureen gage Capello and
I'm an MBA - - here we talk a lot about
culture at Stanford and I wonder for you
you're kind of leading GM through this
merger of cultures of an automotive
world that is kind of slower returns
longer cycles a lot of capital versus
like this technology innovation cycle of
high returns quick innovation and I'm
curious how you think about leading a
company through that and merging those
two cultures together yeah I think it's
one of the ways to do that is you to
bring in talent you know we brought in a
lot of talent who we had a lot of talent
who understood the the vehicle
development cycle that you talked about
the longer capital intensive cycle but
really to do it quickly you had to bring
people in and you had to get them in the
room and get them you know debating it
and coming up with the right answer
because you can do certain things and
especially in the vehicle you know when
you look at all the things you can do in
a vehicle now of connecting your phone
and and all that that different
technology or you're just a different
functionality better word that you can
do in a car now that you couldn't do
five or ten years ago but how that works
be you know how you're technically doing
that and still protecting the breaking
in the steering system but providing all
this functionality is most people don't
understand they'll be like well why
can't I control this well you know
that's pretty core to the the engine
performance type of thing so but getting
getting the two mindsets in the room and
coming up with the winning solution is
the best way to do it fast I found and
and then just you know from a culture
perspective to me when I look at culture
it's about behaviors so when people ask
me you know what are you most worried
about
I'm confident we have good answers but
will we get them to market fast enough
and so constantly r.e.m ffice izing the
speed but yet you know you have to you
can't sometimes an organization
especially an engineering organization
will take you so literally but you have
to make sure that you're talking about
safety and you know you know one of the
things we always say we want results but
we want them with integrity and so it's
really me talking a lot about behaviors
but when you're trying to blend two very
different worlds
you know it's pretty hard to take this
person and/or this person and switch
them and have that be successful but you
put them together and they can be really
powerful
Jim Phelps MBA 79 no Kane no Walker
going back to the breadth versus depth
conversations at your head a while back
I wondered if you might be able to
comment on the increasing push at both
the undergraduate and graduate level to
focus be more capable than moment you
come out commit and pick majors earlier
in graduate school get concentrations
that are more finely tuned and contrast
that with the recent comments by Sam
Palmisano the recently retired chairman
and head of another technical company
IBM and then he says I think we have a
need for more breadth for people that
can communicate can be
cross-disciplinary how do you see that
working out at firm like GM and what can
you say to the student body that's
facing these sorts of questions right
now you know it's really interesting you
know again from a company perspective
I need people who have tremendous depth
you know if you're a chief engineer of a
vehicle that's generally by the time you
get to be achieve you've been in that
vehicle development you know being on a
product program for about 15 years
because the cycles of learning really
being able to make all the decisions to
integrate every single system in the
vehicle the way we do it it's a really
small team that is the chief engineer
and then the you know the the electrical
group and the powertrain group and the
body structures group and the you know
the infotainment they're all coming
together but they're the ones we've got
to make those trade-offs so you know
there's certain areas where we just need
tremendous stuff but you know for so and
then there's areas where you need
somebody say yeah
understand this but I do need the
breasts because you need to make the
trade-off so it's it's kind of you need
to make the trade-offs this way or this
way that's why I say you need both and
I'm going to answer the second part of
it is a mom though I mean so I have a
sophomore in college and a high school
senior and I just you know we are just
asking I go back and not that we can go
back to when I was a kid but you know
how can you know when you're 16 years
old exactly what you want to do for the
rest of your life I mean I'm not sure I
know what I want to do at age 55 for the
rest of my life and so to make PA dies
so I think there's a need to you know if
you're studying engineering to still
have some broadening classes and some
you know some from a from a liberal arts
perspective or you know the the liberal
arts school or to understand philosophy
I think it makes you a better engineer
so this you know I'm only going to do
this and I'm going to focus and I'm
going to be the best person on this one
technology especially this one thing if
you make that decision you know in once
you get into your career I remember one
of the most valued people when I was
running the manufacturing engineering
group was my welding expert and and he
had spent his career becoming a welding
expert you know and grew into that role
and and that's the kind of depth I'm
talking about you need but he probably
made that decision in his 30s or 40s not
at 16 17 18 when you're picking an
undergraduate graduate major so I'm a
big proponent that you know as you're at
a university - yes if you if you know
for sure this is what you want to do I
still think you should get some
broadening classes and challenge
yourself to think a little differently
if you don't know that's okay and then
you need to take a broad sweep so again
I have one child who knows exactly what
he wants to do and I have another who
doesn't and I'm telling them both I you
know take some of those classes that are
going to broaden that you're not sure
about because again I came here thinking
I was kind of checking a box and I
didn't know what I didn't know so it
scares me how were you know pretty soon
you're going to be in middle school that
have to declare a career Christophe
Mayer MBA - I'd love to hear your
perspective
so many companies have entered the
automotive space including tech
companies
what competitor keeps you up at night
well I like to describe ourselves as a
tech company tens of millions of lines
of code in every vehicle but ok but to
your point they all scare me it's my job
to be paranoid about that I mean there
are some incredibly when you look at the
big players in the Chelsea in the
traditional sense that you know the OEMs
they're very capable you know whether
you're talking about Asian competitors
or German competitors Korean competitors
you know very capable so they keep me up
at night and then you know when you look
at the resources that some of the you
know the apples and the googles and and
some of the startups can bring I mean we
bought a start-up because and we made
that decision could we have grown that
talent inside probably it was a heck of
a lot faster to to take somebody who'd
been working on it a couple years and
then marry the two and you know find the
right power so you know whether it's the
big tech companies or the traditional
OEMs or the startups they all worry me
and that's my job to worry about all of
that
Alex manky MBA one most curious to get
your thoughts on the growth of EDS
headwinds and tailwind how fast you
expect them to grow and GM's strategy
within that so from a electric-vehicle
perspective I think it's definitely part
of the the future solution when you look
at the environmental concerns it's
absolutely Sansa is our fuel cells and
we invest heavily in both I think ETS
will come first count it down the
learning curve you know the growth is
going to be because we're still working
on solving the you know the kind of the
energy density issues around batteries
and and the cost issues although you
know we had tremendous learnings from
our first generation volt to our second
generation volts and now the Chevrolet
Volt
you know I keep seeing the costs and the
and the costs come down and the energy
density go up so I believe we're close
in fact General Motors we have put out
externally said we have challenged
ourselves to be the first om or company
that has profitable electric vehicles
that are affordable
because we believe it's so much a part
of the future if
the the biggest volume is going to first
be in China because they're regulating
it and you know when you look at the
size of the Chinese market last year it
was 28 million new vehicles sold whether
it's 18 19 or 20
you know 10% of that market by mandate
will 10 and 12 14 percent will be
electric or either fully easy or plug-in
hybrids so definitely moving you know
here there's still you know there's a
part that's an emotional decision and
then for the bulk of people who buy
vehicles there's a financial decision
and with low gas prices it makes the
equation even a little bit harder but I
believe you're going to in you know five
years it'll be significantly more across
the globe a lot of it does depend on
fuel prices but I think it's a trend
that is an very important technology
that we have to continue to develop
aggressively because it's so important
from an environmental perspective hi
Mary I'm Jeff Howe MBA one you have a
particularly vocal and public investor
in your company right now we've
indicated not 100% in agreement with
everything GM is deciding I was just
curious to hear from you how you think
about managing that dialogue and also
how you think about shareholders in the
context of all stakeholders and Jim well
I mean shareholders are our owners so
they're vitally important and that's why
we spent so much time on this particular
issue to look to see you know hey is
there a good idea here because our job
is to you know do the best for us
responsibly for our shareholders and you
know as we evaluated this issue we
didn't think it was in the best interest
of our shareholders and so you know
that's the real I mean I talk regularly
to multiple shareholders I spent just
two days ago was in Boston meeting with
several shareholders you know spent the
day and I do that quite regularly so I
think it's very important to listen to
your shareholders to understand their
points of view but at the same time then
we you know we have to take all that
information and integrate it and then
understand because we're at the company
you know day in and day out and
understand you know maybe at a level
deeper because we spend 24/7 on it and
so you've got to look at what's the
decision let's take all that input now
let you know and let's understand what
we're doing is there is there a way we
can improve our strategy is there a
different capital allocation decision we
can make we've always got to stay open
to that because not every good idea is
going to necessarily come from the
company so that's the way a hugely value
my shareholders and feel feel it's
vitally important to listen to on a very
regular basis
Shanny a class of oh seven and also GM
shareholder oh oh i requested about
automated cars assuming that the future
includes automated cars talking to each
other through a port protocol my
question is how do you think we're going
to get there do you think the market is
going to pick a winner among you know
OMS or tech companies traditional tech
companies or do you think government's
going to you know set a standard or play
a role well I think if you're if you're
going to have the vehicle-to-vehicle
communications which we actually you
know have a vehicle that has that
capability on it now it's pretty limited
because it's one model I think the
government has to play a role
then there's already a you know standard
set and you know a spectrum dedicated to
it but I think what's happening because
that's at you know think about it every
cars got to have the technology you've
got a carpet you know the car park right
now in the United States is 240 million
vehicles so and if you you know at a
rate of a pretty strong market now of
seventeen and a half million vehicles a
year with cars out of there it's a long
journey to have fully v2v capability
although there's probably some things
you can do but then you you know of
adding the technology to other vehicles
you know certainly but so I think that's
a part as we go and it's V to V V to I
needed V to infrastructure as well but I
think what's happening in autonomous
vehicles now because that's a longer
journey you know you've got a lot of the
car the cars gotta you know really to do
an autonomous vehicle you need to
control it you need to know three things
precisely where am I precisely what's
happening around me and therefore third
what path do I take safely and you know
we're doing that with other technologies
but you know clearly the V to V and the
VDI technology I think down the road
has it taken to even another level of
that only safety but efficiency but were
ways off hi
I'm in I'm gonna be a one when you guys
are talking about the roles that cars
have played in American culture really
resonated with me because I'm from Texas
and so I was wondering if you could
comment a little bit about how you see
the role of cars and maybe more
specifically GM playing in the next
generation of Americana well again if I
as I started a conversation I think it's
our job to not say here customers the
solution for you but to listen to the
customer and say you know what is
technology enable us to do you know how
our city is changing how its
transportation changing and then provide
the most efficient best and you know
solution from a customer's perspective
so I think one of the key things we need
to do is really understand what the
technology is capable of doing not only
in a whole new world opens up when you
have autonomous vehicles of what do you
do in the vehicle because you're still
going to have that you know at least for
a period of time the physical you know
time of getting from point A to point B
how do we make that more efficient how
do we make the environment what you're
able to do I mean they're so that's why
it's so exciting right now to be in the
in the auto business or in the
transportation business because there's
all you know it's really we have to be
customer driven in how we deploy the
technology most efficiently because I
think that's that's who wins a good
afternoon
startup saying I'm a sex program when
you got into GM the way I look at it it
was like starting up 100 year old
company
what were your biggest challenges when
you got into that role and you have to
like jumpstart something that's been
around for so long are you talking about
when I became the CEO yesterday okay you
know I had been part of the the
leadership the senior leadership team
for a you know a handful of years before
I had the opportunity to be the CEO so
we were already working on transforming
the culture simplifying the company
eliminating bureaucracy you know making
sure people were empowered to do their
best so I'd been kind of been on that
journey so a lot of it was
continuing and accelerating the work
that we were doing to to you know kind
of else they push the reset button after
the bankruptcy with the company and a
lot of it really gets to behavior so if
you if you subscribe that you know most
people come to work every day and they
want to do a good job what's getting in
their way you know do we have an
environment and a collaborative
environment and the tools that are
necessary so you can do your best work
or do we you know is it painful to get
the most simple tasks done and so a lot
of it was just continuing to make sure
that you know processes and systems were
efficient and we're giving people the
right tools and we're giving them the
right training and then empowering them
and that's the journey we've been on I
would say since even before I had the
role and continue to do that today we
you know spend a lot of time working on
what are the right behaviors what are
the company's values and how do we
really infuse that because you know then
it gets to that capturing the hearts and
minds of everybody that are going to
deliver superior results unfortunately
that is all we have time for so please
join me and thank you very much
you
[Music]